I've always been interested in living a sustainable life,...
...but how much impact can just one person make?
I knew real change would only come...
...by providing other people with the means to live more sustainably.
I cofounded Kyoto's first zero-waste supermarket,...
...where you can buy what you need without any plastic packaging.
My name is Mariko McTier.
In 2018, I came across an entire beach covered in single-use PET bottles.
I thought, clean tap water is readily available in Japan...
...if only people used it more often.
This simple idea led to MyMizu,...
...an app that connects users...
...with over 200,000 free water refill points globally.
Our users are constantly adding new locations...
...and participating businesses are growing daily.
There is still so much work ahead,...
...but I believe we can change...
...the way people think about sustainability and their impact on the world.